police are calling this a targeted
and cowardly act of gun violence
investigators say three people
reportedly armed with assault rifles and
pistols
stepped out of a car and began firing
indiscriminately
into a crowd gathered to see a rap
concert these yellow markers an
indication of how many rounds were fired
two died on the scene and at least 20
people were injured
some severely my daughter ended up
getting shot in the middle of this
i don't even know uh words can't explain
how i feel right now man
this is a this is a sad moment
but it's a time when the community needs
to come together
instead of tearing apart families and
friends of the victims gathered outside
local hospitals for news
of their loved ones police are appealing
for information calling the suspected
shooters
cold-blooded killers we're working
really hard but
it's very difficult to stop a small
amount of individuals who want to go out
there and commit murder
and it takes all of us to stop this and
and we really have to put the work in
this summer to keep our children
our community safe this latest mass
shooting comes just days after nine
people
at a california train yard were killed
by a lone gunman
police in san jose said the gunman had
12 firearms and more than
twenty thousand rounds of ammunition it
begs the damn question what the hell is
going on in the united states of america
the hell is wrong with us and when are
we gonna come to grips with this
according to the gun violence archive
the u.s has recorded
over 200 mass shootings so far this year
president joe biden calls gun violence
in the u.s an epidemic
and has called for common sense reforms
to things like background checks
and a ban on what he calls weapons of
war
change though needs to be approved by
congress with the support of at least 10
republicans
making it highly unlikely andy gallacher
al jazeera
miami florida